[Music]
you're one talented girl Annie LeBlanc
you started out as a super talented
gymnast but years later you got famous
after appearing on your family's YouTube
vlog we love the music you've created
and your amazing singing voice too just
when we thought you couldn't get any
more talented you started acting on
chicken girls seriously
annie is there anything you or your
sister can't do Oh sweetie
when they heard I wanted the role no one
tried out Annie and Hailey leblanc are
two super talented sisters but how much
do you really know about them keep
watching for ten awesome facts about the
leblanc sisters why are people watching
us the truth behind Brad Olay the
LeBlanc family has been blocking on Brad
Olay since December 30th 2010 but this
wasn't supposed to be a vlog for the
entire family it was just supposed to be
a channel for Haley who was only a
toddler the channel name is a
combination of rat and Haley they
realized that she was cute and hilarious
and put a video on YouTube but soon
Bradley turned into a tan offer their
whole family they show their daily life
and all their adventures stop growing up
so fast you're still my little sister
Eileen agent snatcher the third LeBlanc
Annie and Hailey are super close sisters
there are only four years between the
two of them but there used to be three
of the blonde siblings her older brother
Caleb used to appear on their family
vlog
[Music]
sadly Kayla passed away in 2015 from a
heart issue the family still honors his
memory in a lot of ways though they miss
him a lot
both Annie and Hailey say that 7 is
their lucky number because it was
Caleb's lucky number first youtube idols
it might be strange to find out that
YouTube stars have their own favorite
youtubers but they do the world of
YouTube is huge and the leblanc sisters
have their favorite channels just like
we do
Haley's favorite youtuber is Alyssa
Marie Alicia's vlog covers everything
from beauty and fashion to DIYs and
pranks any totally fangirls over Liza
Kashi an actress with a popular YouTube
channel she even ran all over a hotel
with a friend to find Liza and meet her
medical stories it's easy to forget that
famous people are real and have their
own issues they have to
the doctor and have medical procedures
done just like everyone else
hailey was born with the lazy eye lazy
eyes may not seem like a big deal but if
they don't get treated they can cause
blindness
she had corrective surgery for it when
she was younger and she's fine now
hailey has also had to get stitches
before ouch
love story Annie is currently living out
her own sweet love story fans of her
Instagram have probably seen a familiar
face in her posts annie is dating Asher
angel from Disney Channel's Andy Mac and
they are just so cute together and he
appeared in Asher's music video one
thought away and the two just hit it off
one thought away is like to me it's
basically about this girl that I just
can't get off my mind we love seeing all
their posts on Instagram they even wore
a couples costume for Halloween this
year they went as lilo and stitch cutest
pets we absolutely love it when the
LeBlanc pets show up on their vlogs the
LeBlanc family definitely has a
preference for dogs with smooshed faces
Piper is an adorable boxer she's been in
the family the longest gigi is a cute
brindle French Bulldog she is probably
the most popular of the dogs and don't
forget Winnie the precious American
Bulldog Halley also has a pet bunny
named frisbee that is just the cutest
name ever
which LeBlanc pet is your favorite
fantastic at gymnastics annie is a very
accomplished gymnast she actually got
her youtube start on a channel called
acro Anna she posted tutorials and
videos from her gymnastics meets she was
just three when acro Anna started
Annie continued to study gymnastics
until 2017 Halley also studied
gymnastics for a few years she wasn't
quite as into it as her older sister
though she was a level 3 gymnast when
she stopped after four years people if
they meet us like I meet they're like I
started gymnastics because of my exactly
all over the world the LeBlanc family
lives in Los Angeles it's a lot easier
for the girls to have their acting and
music careers out there but they didn't
always live there they had a house in
Maryland and for a long time they flew
back and forth between there in
California but when Annie was really
young her dad was in the Navy so they
moved around a lot annie has lived in
Japan and Texas too she doesn't remember
a lot
about it because she was so small first
heartbreak before she started dating
Asher and he was dating Hayden summer
all the two were chicken girls co-stars
and they even made music together but
apparently their breakup wasn't pretty
Annie said that he turned out to be
someone she couldn't trust she also
really wanted her heartbreak to be
private but he posted about it on the
Internet
boys suck we can't imagine how worse a
breakup is when you have millions of
followers but she definitely seems happy
now big dreams Annie and Haley have
definitely not stopped dreaming
Annie's dream is to release a full album
and sell out an arena for a concert she
also wants to start her own clothing
line one day Haley is continuing to
focus on acting and singing she has
several youtube channels including Jam
Junior and she is racking up quite a
following on social media these two
sisters are so talented we know they'll
continue to achieve awesome things are
you a friend of rattle a let us know in
the comments thanks for watching be sure
to give this video a big thumbs up and
don't forget to subscribe we'll see you
next time on the things